So we're going to define what is context and tell you how
to get it just right. But first, we're going to hear from
a user that we visited back in lesson one and he's
going to tell us how he feels when we get context wrong.
>> An app I really like is ESPN Scorecenter but what,
there's a feature about it that I really don't like. Well,
I do like, but not at all times. It, it will
send you updates of things that are happening in the sports
world. I don't care about everything that's happening in the sports
world. I don't want it to text me at 2 a.m
and wake me up to tell me that you know somebody
caught the world's biggest fish or whatever. That, that doesn't, I don't
care about it. So it seems like Clark experienced a UX fail.
>> I know, it's really sad, but it could have
been avoided. Which one of these sensors would you use
to make sure that Clark doesn't get woken up in
the middle of the night with information he doesn't want?